the question over whether prosecutors
marcia clark and christopher darden were
a real life item has been captivating
viewers on the People vs OJ Simpson ET
sat down exclusively with Darden himself
for a wide-ranging interview where he
expertly addressed the romance rumors
can we talk a little bit about marcia
smile would you say that you guys dated
no no I've never really dated anyone
really really did you want to date her I
wouldn't know how to date were you
interested in her um I was interested in
her well-being yes did you ever kiss
Marcia Clark kiss her in a way other
than a friendly hello or friendly
goodbye did you ever kiss her say I'm
blushing
um I don't recall ever doing that no did
you have a thing for Marcia Clark come
on well we can't let it to bed now and
then no one will ever have to ask you
again what a Marsha say well here's
exactly what she told et last September
Chris was Chris and I were trench mates
and he he kept me from just utter
depression so many days so how they or
haven't they Sarah Paulson who plays
Clark on the series told et she has her
own take uh you know it felt to me like
there was something going on no people
say well what was their relationship but
whatever our relationship wasn't people
out there don't know what our
relationship with us for more from our
interview with Darden and what he really
thinks of the show tune into et Tuesday